à
m
matteau oublié sur une côte africaine
mirage de ciel flamboyant rêve d'une
autre vie rêve d'acier de folie bref de
boules
quarante ans déjà la création de la
mauritanie
les prémices de l'industrie le minerai
du désert et tous en bas
tout se vend le sol les fonds marins les
eaux les plus poissonneuses du monde
mais aussi son âme sa foi ultime témoin
de la civilisation du désert les nomades
se sont sédentarisés beaucoup ont gagné
les villes à la recherche de prétendus
bienfaits d'une civilisation occidentale
d'autres sont restés sous la tente à
vivre à écouter le sable le temps le
coeur ce sont peut-être les derniers des
juste ici ou confins du sahara
occidental et de l'atlantique sur plus
d'un million de kilomètres carrés de
sable
la mauritanie est devenue une nation en
1958 en serre et au nord par le maroc au
sud par le sénégal à l'est par l'algérie
et le mali ce pays fut pendant des
siècles parcouru par des nomades
berbères et arabes
aujourd'hui la plupart de ces deux
millions d'habitants sont devenus
sédentaires
nouakchott la capitale a été créée de
toutes pièces
au moment de l'indépendance waliboo
anciennement port etienne est devenue la
deuxième ville avec son terminal
minéralier ou est acheminé le faire que
l'on extrait du désert sur cette terre
des hommes de mermoz et de saint-exupéry
le monde moderne cherche à accroître son
emprise et ceux qui vivent perdent peu à
peu leur père dans cette mutation
inévitable des hommes ont cependant
préservé l'idéal des anciens nomades une
éternelle et rance pour parfaire sa vie
[Musique]
mahmoud habite au centre de la
mauritanie dans une ancienne ville
sainte de l'islam chinguetti son univers
il de chéri c'est pourquoi il fait
souvent office de guide et communiquent
à tous sa joie de vivre
[Musique]
taleb plus pondéré s'est forgé une
philosophie sereine de la vie les
pêcheurs sur les bords de l'atlantique
sa fortune principale réside dans la
contemplation du désert et des vagues de
l'océan ou bakar le plus solitaire est
aussi le plus entouré n'a de passion que
pour les gamins à qui il dispense des
cours de français dans un petit village
de l'est du pays
[Musique]
entre ciel et d'une sous le regard
impassible du destin tous trois chemine
sur un même itinéraire
celui qui ouvre les portes d'un certain
bonheur
[Musique]
pas très loin de chinguetti mammouth
s'est arrêtée dans l'oasis de sa famille
qu'ils visitent chaque mois ce n'est pas
un simple devoir
il aime retrouver les siens ses racines
l'accueil et la bienveillance de la
palmeraie les chaînes d'itv pièce
pas question de transiger sur les
palabres d' usage les curiosités à
satisfaire et la tension à dispenser
jusqu'à plus petits félicite pascal
cette fois je l'écris tout l'alphabet
arabe tous
[Musique]
moi que j'étais encore ce jeu conduisait
comme cela maintenant je faisais la
petite voiture j'ai dit oh je retiens
attirer nous les bons mais non le ce
pour les enfants aussi
mahmoud à la simplicité des sages la
sérénité et la confiance dans une
existence où tout est à construire sans
aide sans sécurité il vit le désert au
rythme du temps de ses facéties de ses
colères et remercie allah pour ses
bienfaits
ça c'est mon terrain le palmarès de mon
père on cultive au moment où on avait
beaucoup de cuir que je devais pastèque
sorgho le mil
quand il parle depuis longtemps
rezé les palmeraies pour faire le date
maintenant un peu de temps on revient
pour enlever les arbres qui n'est pas
importante pour que ne pas serrer le
jardin quoi donc ne pas bouffer tout le
contenu tous les lots quand on donne nos
moments dingues et non une grande
palmeraie comme ça on goûte retire le
dater puis on descend tout ça c'est le
sac qu'il en a mis le doigt dedans pour
conserver avant cinq à la baule
bref reçu
[Musique]
le sable le rock la modeste terre des
oasis l'astreinte du climat façonnent
les peuples de l'immense haras chacun
apprend à économiser en permanence l'eau
ses forces et ses animaux
[Musique]
le domaine de mammuth c'est la dra sans
doute la plus belle région de la
mauritanie
[Musique]
à 500 km à l'ouest le sahara meur sur
une de ses longues plages qui bordent
l'atlantique
ces capteurs farid ici c'est en une
réserve naturelle connu sous le nom de
banc d'arguin
dans ce coin perdu et ignoré des
touristes des hommes en quête d'avenir
se sont regroupés dans un village
abandonné l'homme au turban noir s'étale
m
il fait fonction de chef son camarade
c'est buhari
la mer est leur seule ressource ils
l'aiment et la respectent comme le
désert chaque jour les mêmes gestes se
répète
au moyen d'un mois pour appeler les
forces armées lyon damas on met les
filets de matin à l'écran le matin
l'homme revient le lendemain à la même
heure des filets le disque est dedans et
on les sifflets à sa place des dorades
roses et droit droit y aller badèche
débat dans ce bout du monde il y as ni
chômeur ni assisté
chacun vit de rien et se contente de peu
les difficultés sont monnaie courante
comme retrouver un filet poser la veille
non
notre pêche site
dix ans c'est une pêche de subsistance
c'est un peu ce dégrilleur c'est pour
vivre l'arête de poisson on le fait
c'est chez nous il a zappé la crise
l'été il a toujours existé depuis des
lustres depuis des années nous nous
aidera grands parents donc j'ai habité
ici
[Musique]
oh
daniel personnes vont habiter civile a
jusqu en cinq ans et sont repartis sur
de lévis et en avril 94
je suis ici je suis un loser sous une
tente
oui je vais qui 2 3 1 de 15 900 santé
oms père était déjà vide pour tard et
c'est là je suis parti en eau du budget
feu de camp j'ai été rejoint par la pâte
comme tout tout tout le monde attend que
j'ai quitté l'école
j'ai fait toutes ces années en ville
j'ai tapé à toutes les portes
ces parties par trous j'ai tenté tout
quitte les chances j'en ai paye en
heureusement toutes les portes se sont
refermées devant moi et j'ai voulu
comment dirais-je
je suis venu ici pour exploiter les
richesses dont nous disposons ici il
puis si tout cela
on a la pêche les poissons dessous du
minimum vital le strict minimum vital
pas toujours on l'a on a mangé on aboie
on a le calme de l'opo pas de stress et
on a deux heures à deux kilomètres voilà
le grand désert
la fascination du désert et permanente
même pour ses habitants dans son vide
son silence dans son espace infini le
sahara reste un lieu de mystère et de
spiritualité
[Musique]
oh
très loin l'est du pays coincé entre les
dunes et une colline qu'amour s'étale au
bord de la seule route goudronnée qui
mène à la frontière du mali
[Musique]
encore maintenant
à
comme dans tous les pays d'afrique les
enfants sont nombreux suivant le choix
de leur famille ils suivent un
enseignement public ou coranique à
l'école primaire et laïque on inculque
que la nouvelle notion de patrie
étrangère aux générations précédentes
les cours sont dispensés en arabe mais
quelques heures par semaine sont
consacrées aux français boubacar en est
le responsable
[Musique]
c'est une école primaire de la 1re à la
6e année les fréquenter par 300 élèves
dont la majorité des garçons six mètres
du travail
remettre le français c'est moi pourquoi
devient ton inquisiteur voix devient
enfin ça dépend de la personne peut-être
la personne est amoureuse des métiers si
je peux m'exprimer ainsi
ça je parle de mon cas moi je suis de
juristes se passe-t-il 2008 y écrivait à
partir de la troisième année
[Musique]
vingt-cinq heures n'aura par semaine
donc de palier au moins deux mètres le
français vainqueur le français par
seconde j'aime dans ce métier des
enfants que ce métier tu met en contact
des enfants deviennent des enfants
je m'occupais des enfants sur amoureux
des enfants
tout ce que les enfants d'une trace
[Musique]
la vocation de boubacar remonte à son
adolescence il a suivi l'école normale à
rosso dans le sud du pays
on l'a affecté ici et même s'il regrette
l'éloignement de sa famille
il a trouvé l'épanouissement dans
l'exercice de son métier
[Musique]
mais c'est aussi un contemplatif
il médite sur le monde la vie à la fois
pour la meilleure adaptation
la religion comme beaucoup plus c'est un
[Musique]
repère si pour moi que je trouve très
sûrement très sécurisant roland
[Musique]
le désert témoigne de la perpétuelle
mutation de la terre et de la vie au
paléolithique le sahara était une région
humide avec une terre luxuriante et d
eau qui coule et en abondance
l'évolution des hommes et à son image
une loi dont on ne définit pas toujours
le dessin mais qui comptera à s'adapter
[Musique]
pour moi je préfère celui qui est mieux
que toute la vie de mauritania parce que
d'abord c'est en ville sainte de l'islam
qui les habitants des chalets divers cas
c'est très très riches qui sont
sympathiques pour moi
la première charité d'abord il était
construit alors 160 à la jirs 772 de
leurs relations
elle était très peu qui étaient
présentes comme en centre- caravaniers
interne et l'afrique du nord de
l'afrique de l'ouest
ils ont installé ils ont construit
beaucoup de diversité coranique beaucoup
des mosquées à 12 il avait rejoint y
avait douze mosquée et beaucoup
d'universités coranique ya beaucoup de
monde qui vient de l'afrique étudie le
duc aura fait la prière dans sa mosquée
là c'est pour cela que les thérapies les
villes saintes de l'islam la ville ici
c'est la vie passé abandonné montana et
à eau des maisons qui sont habitées
parce que les gens ils ont abandonné à
cause de la chaussée reste vive au coq
il ya déjà qu'il voulait tomber dans la
vie moderne est en charge de la maison
ils ont habité dans la nouvelle ville et
a déjà aussi qu'ils sont capables de le
syndic qui complètement à cause de
l'économie c'est très faible
ces procédés qui déjà abandonné
maisons habitées
guide de coeur mahmoud conduit souvent
les visiteurs dans la petite
bibliothèque de sa famille aux 14e et
15e siècle de nombreux les traits et
marabouts travailler dans la ville
caravanières ils ont laissé d'importants
ouvrages dont de nombreux manuscrits
mais voilà ce qu'ils sont des livres qui
s'était créé un aveuglement lehmann ses
cris ont produit dans les boîtes ce
n'est qu'on l'a mis dans les cartons là
on enrage ici sur l'âge venant peu le
sourire
les sénateurs qui sont pas dans les
boîtes c'est déjà un copier avec
imprimante et la bibliothèque c'est une
bibliothèque 3 me c'est un polar ma
famille même et se maquille les
responsables en somme c'est moi qui
s'occupe de l'entretien de deux livres
quotidienne qui a réagi ce matin lâche
tout
cet argument est ce cru 2
le casier en scène
c'est pas venu voir
de la loire un point noir du prophète
par ja matoury paroisse
c'est à jean getty que se regrouper tous
les pèlerins de la drave se rendant à la
mecque
l'esprit du passé imprègne encore le
village de sérénité même si les vents
poussent les sables à ensevelir
inexorablement ce haut lieu de prière
inchallah si dieu le veut
un capteur farid le poisson est rien il
s'agira quelques jours au soleil puis
sera stocker jusqu'à l'arrivée d'un
acheteur venez à 260 km au nord de
nouakchott 200 milles d'ouest au sud-est
de noix du monde et convoyés par voiture
taxi brousse ou tard à des terrasses
région en commençant bien ici les vaches
à nouakchott où un toit du bus ce qu'on
allait venturi du poisson on n'a jamais
vraiment calculé ça mais si c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas vraiment grand chose
ça peut avoisiner par exemple à peu près
de vela dieu libye a par mois 300 francs
300 ici artis n'a que 2 de petite
chaloupe de petits chalets premier on
n'a pas le droit d'avoir ici un bateau à
moteur est que nous sommes dans un parc
naturel dans une distance et raisins
nous sommes un peu à la merci de ce
qu'on appelle le vent ici le vent les
hélicos
[Musique]
la situation de la communauté précaire
mais il n'y a pas de rancoeur de
jalousie de recherche de besoins
infondées l'acceptation de sa condition
d'homme des gens heureux de vivre
[Musique]
deux cars north
tous
1 bernard
ce soir en parlant de bruce labruce ces
quelques kilomètres à l'intérieur des
terres là où commence à s'accrocher les
épineux les nomades viennent au hasard
si installé pour quelques temps dans les
campements se perpétue les traditions
ancestrales
ici on bat et on tisse le poil de
chameau une matière première
indispensable à la fabrication des
tentes qui abritent les tribus mêlée à
la laine de mouton noir le poil de
chameau assure été comme hiver la
meilleure isolation ainsi se
confectionne un grand rectangle qui
donne naissance à une tante l'arime à
qui accueille familles invitées
l'hospitalité est une règle obligatoire
tout étranger doit être accueillie logé
et nourri autant de temps qu'ils
désirent rester le désert convient à
cette solidarité
elle s'apprécie dans la simplicité et le
partage de moments magiques
m
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que l'on vit à cap tafari et
ses environs dans la tranquillité le
bien-être les yeux tournés vers la mer
ou le désert on a l'innocence et la
force des purs que détiennent tous les
enfants du monde
tant qu'ils n'en sont pas des possédés
par de faux dieux
ah ah
ac amour le sport c'est la sphère des
maîtres d'école
qu'importe le manque de moyens les
vêtements inadapté ce qui compte c'est
se détendre et s'amuser dans le village
la bonne humeur est constante certes il
n'y a pas d'électricité pas d'eau
courante cinéma et télévision sont
inconnus mêlant vit bien avec les moyens
du bord les classes se tiennent parfois
dans des pièces de maisons louées à
l'année on a payé en amont at elle doit
siffler quand l'enfant a h1n1
[Musique]
l'écriture du français tient un rôle
moteur dans l'enseignement car les
enfants assimilent plus facilement que
le langage les critiques ne pas comme le
langage effectué il suffit de dessiner
et lettres donc là cet apprentissage
pour nous ici est plus facile que de les
faire apprendre à parler donc séparé
chose il acquiert très vite
zac et très vite les critiques alors que
le langage est venu tardivement petit à
petit a joué avec 6 10 et ses camarades
mais les garçons l'ont poussé génie gêné
ajouté jamais les nous avons ya la
relation
10 le matin à 10 heures les élèves
sortants récréation récréation il n'y a
pas beaucoup de moyens à l'école nous
les maîtres ne manque de culot les
élèves n'ont pas là où ce soir donc ce
soit aux facteurs ils n'ont pas aussi de
lui ni de payer donc ça manque vraiment
de l'effet qu'il est exclu qu'il puisse
dire ça à la maison n'ont pas de venir à
la maison
beaucoup d'emplois
[Musique]
j'ai passé assez devenir comme on m'a
fait venir cette marque holmes
ici à commander ici dans les grandes
vacances je vais voir dans ce numéro se
poursuit très loin de 6 et 7 5 le
médecin dense et très loin nous pour
aller les voir tout un léger reçoit
quand même de mauvais tours
[Musique]
non
ça demande beaucoup de préparation du
faux parce que récuse la boutique manade
répète ça me suis entraîné des pertes
allemandes entre sa batterie puis ce
sont des mères place tu joues
on peut ne pas s'informer c'est la
dictée du coran deuxième à table chez
mon livre
après ça j'ai quelques bouquins avec moi
[Musique]
je ne sais pas encore mais mon salaire
pour moins de 600 francs français s'est
pas beaucoup parce exemple faire marrer
à gérer la maison familiale qui reçoit
souvent des visiteurs est une des tâches
principales de mahmoud la tradition du
désert la plus vivante et celle du thé
que l'on savoure plusieurs fois par jour
sa préparation est un rituel et une
cérémonie où l'on ne cesse de transvaser
le liquide
[Musique]
ah ah
certains appelle ironiquement le thé le
whisky mauritanienne car dans ce pays
musulman d'alcool est interdite les
griots sont musiciens chanteurs ou
danseurs tous appartiennent à la même
caste
[Rires]
la vie et la survie des griots sont
essentiellement liées à leur musique
seul le rapporte quelques revenus lors
des cérémonies et des fêtes
ils viennent avec leur famille flatter
les puissants en chantant leur offrez et
leurs louanges
ils sont à la fois choyé grains ou
détesté
car ils peuvent tourner en ridicule ceux
qui refuseraient de leur donner de
l'argent
le griot vos charmants ça c'est les gens
qui sont un joueur la musique
traditionnelle il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont bien seule musique parfois quand
aussi on voulait faire un mariage gay
vite ils auront joué petit dit
[Musique]
m
[Rires]
dans l'ancienne maison des marchands
mahmoud a rassemblé différents objets de
la tradition saharienne sur lesquels il
veille presque religieusement vois ta
tête pour transporter le matériel dtc
les gens de caravanes qui sont en jeu
c'est rythme les motards se sont des
nomades qui sont aime bien garder leurs
traditions ils sont le sens de
l'hospitalité
là aussi c'est le musulman
[Rires]
les femmes vivent dans cette société à
l'écart des hommes même si elles
régissent le commerce et la vie
familiale
mahmoud aiment bien leur compagnie il se
rend souvent dans cette coopérative où
l'on fabrique différents vêtements ou
parure autres lieux de prédilection pour
mahmoud l'ancien fort français de
chinguetti érigé à l'opposé de
l'ancienne ville
je vais en suivant ainsi parce qu'ici
c'est un meilleur endroit pour nous tous
les soirs l'après katheria jusqu'à 6h30
d'un bond le paysage depuis un an
beaucoup de bruit ces cadres fait
tranquille pour moi
[Musique]
attachement à l'histoire et à son époque
coloniale les vestiges de
l'administration française trône encore
mais s'étiole au fil des ans
à capter farid un nouveau fil et mis en
place sous l'oeil vigilant de talent
aime rester aujourd'hui sur la plage
c'est un rêve des pêcheurs c'est avoir
un bon bateau une langue en bateau voit
ce qu'on appelle ici manche
si le canadien
et les exploiter le bois exploité
l'exploiter la merde
plutôt à part
voilà aller un peu plus loin
pêcher dans des endroits où il ya plus
de poissons être un plaisir de revenir
au village
on est à la merci du rang quand le vent
souffle et tests
on a toujours peur d'aller en mer parce
qu'on est entraînée par le courant vers
l'ouest vers le large
il faut combattre quant aux régions ne
pas attraper une vague à lyon en vente
ap l'intérieur je suis profondément que
rien céder
recherchez les mots
c'est toujours difficile de s'exprimer
entre sa langue maternelle
a lyon comme dit le grand philosophe
khadir c'est la plume des peuples dans
son aparté une envie de existait des
livres de ne pas céder à la tentation
d'avoir d'être honnête
comment dirais-je de travailler dur
pourtant pas rire
[Musique]
et dès mon prochain roman mon semblable
allen
moi
[Musique]
on va de temps en temps sur la falaise
réfléchit à la ligne c'est quand on a
les filets à sec
quand on met des filets à si vous parlez
pour les nettoyer des alliés un athée
sansal ou sinon quand il n'y a pas assez
de façon d'affilée comment faire manger
tout le monde
moi heureusement on est toujours servi
par ma mère je dirais qu'on peut appeler
la faillite les coins à la touche menu
jeudi dans la baie et sa numéro 10
truites de badech les cordes de grosses
prises afin qu'ils vont se faire 26-26
d'avis comme illégaux
allez on dirait mais 6,7 kg
l'après-midi prendra fin avec le thé
préparé par les deux seules femmes
présentes au village en ce moment
à
ac amour boubacar habite tout près de
l'école coranique du village la
concurrente en quelque sorte de l'école
primaire on l'appelle une madre là
d'autres enfants ils suivent un
enseignement uniquement religieux le
plus jeune à 7 ans il ne reste pendant
longtemps il y en a qui restent en a 15
ans ceux qui viennent à jallo débutant
il y en a qui laisse pendant 7 ans 6 ans
et emma ce afin d'étendre les moyens
dont ils disposent sont aussi modeste
une tablette un encrier une plume d'eau
[Musique]
cole au courant ce qui a attrait à au
courant roc dans les quotidiens on a en
plus du coran on a d'autres matières qui
ne sont pas enseignées dans la madrague
apports de la colonisation
l'école primaire est une nouvelle
tradition qui supplante peu à peu la
pratique des maderas
[Musique]
dans sa pédagogie
boubacar met en scène des jeux qui
maintiennent l'attention des élèves en
carton oui mon cartable mon cartable
[Musique]
le jardin c'est une de mes autres
passions ça fait partie aussi de mes
passe-temps favori
edit yves de carottes de betteraves
le chien le titre ice et
j'ai une ambition particulière
et le devenir un jour un inspecteur de
l'enseignement fondamental
seulement je veux j'ai regardé le
contact que j'ai eu avec les enfants un
inspecteur souvent en rapport avec des
enfants ce jour c'est toujours la
continuté 2
les contacts avec les enfants
vous aime les gens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]
souvent les femmes se respecte dans le
monde
c'est le seul moyen de me mettre en
contact avec le monde extérieur
[Musique]
abeba le paillage et on dit non au nid
d'oiseau à nouveau par une ombrelle ma
nouveau bar et moi je souris quand même
personne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ainsi va la vie à jean getty un capteur
farid houas qu'amour les ventes
transporte et façonne en permanence les
dunes sous le regard du ciel impassible
mahmoud
taleb et boubacar construisent leur vie
et leur univers doux est absente
tutto médiocrité
à l'écouté du désert de dieu et des
hommes ses fils des sables ont
entrouvert les portes du paradis parce
que je suis très content ce que j'ai
essayé d'écrire le monde de walt disney
lèvres malras et surtout parce que je
suis très contente de s'être plasma
[Musique]
bon